alors que certains français sont opposés
à la vaccination et que la vigilance
autour du port du masque et des gestes
barrières semblent diminuer certaines
histoires nous rappelle à la réalité de
la gravité de lakovic 19
c'est le cas par exemple de la terrible
histoire de yoann un jeune homme de 36
ans qui n'est pas considéré comme une
personne à risque mais qui a connu
l'enfer après avoir contracté le
coronavirus il est avec nous ce soir
pour nous raconter son incroyable
épreuve au chu de caen une épreuve de
deux semaines au cours de laquelle yoann
a frôlé la mort et avec yoann
ce père de famille qui est passé proche
de la mort en octobre dernier
yoann pagny et sa femme emily bonsoir
merci d'être là ça va sa maman n'y aura
pas friand c'est pas la folie non ewan
vous venez de kong
vous êtes père de deux petites filles
zoé et manon pauvre petite fille sont en
coulisses je crois qu'on est avec vous
on va expliquer votre longue descente
aux enfers parce qu'il a eu une descente
aux enfers de fulda il a 36 ans 36 ans
yohann ça démarre en septembre labour
chanter les premiers symptômes
ouais perte de goût l'odorat des maux de
tête violents
donc je décide d'aller faire un test et
quatre jours après ressort négatif
donc je comprends pas donc je laisse je
laisse passer les symptômes
disparaissent au bout d'une dizaine de
jours et ça c'est la première étape donc
vous perdez goût l'odorat tess négative
ou libon continuer votre vie normalement
et là vous sentez que votre votre est à
son pire fin octobre fin octobre je
commence je commence à avoir des des
maux de tête violents
je monte en fièvre pendant trois jours
et je vais faire un second test donc qui
ressort positif j'appelle j'appelle le
samu je leur dis bah voila j'ai j'ai
tous les symptômes du dico ville est là
ils me disent de suite si vous avez la
possibilité de vous emmener aller aux
urgences du chu de caen
donc la jv et puis et puis voilà c'est
c'est le début d'une belle descente car
là vous voyez
racontez nous ce que vous voyez quand
vous arrivez dans votre chambre alors je
vois je vois un monsieur un petit peu
plus vieux que moi
42 ans lui est là depuis une semaine il
est sourd aux petits flot d'encre
oxygène de base
et puis il m'explique que c'est un
mauvais moment à passer
mais que ça va bien se passer pour le
coup donc moi je me dis à l'âge que j'ai
j'ai pas de pas de risque je suis pas un
risque et je me dis voilà ça ça va
passer comme une lettre à la poste est
en fait en fait non quoi est votre état
s'empire de plus en plus vous êtes passé
ensuite sous oxygène
ouais là à ce moment là et milliers ce
que vous commencez à être inquiète
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup hélas hélas
vous montrer très ému encore un là vous
vous dites quoi vous dit vous êtes
conscient de ce qui se passe ouais ouais
parce que le troisième jour on décide de
me descendre en réanimation
parce que le taux d'oxygène baisse et la
saturation est pas bonne du tout donc là
je descends réa et je vois une équipe
qui vraiment qu'ils se précipitent
autour de moi et qu'il me dise voilà
c'est la situation est vraiment critique
et on va être obligé de vous un tube et
parce que il vous faut un maximum
d'oxygène dans les poumons et pour la
première fois de ma vie
j'entends ce ce médecin qui est devant
moi et qui me dit monsieur banny la
situation est grave il faut que vous en
ayez conscience
le pronostic vital est plus qu'engagé
et je vais être franc avec vous parce
que je dois pas vous je dois pas vous le
cacher mais vous risquez de mourir
emilie les médecins vous dis la même
chose pratiquement oui ils viennent vous
voir ils vous disent quoi parce que vous
avez deux petites filles j'ai deux
petites filles je j'arrive au chu
mercredi je dépose et tout a été très
vite parce que le vendront le vendredi
ça s'est empiré
tu as changé ils étaient bas en réa le
samedi et j'ai pas pu aller le voir du
tout donc j'ai quand même je sais quand
mélo su enrayer
et là on m'a dit non vous n'avez pas le
droit de rentrer et en fait je me suis
retrouvé un peu comme à la télé on dit
venez on va vous parler
j'étais dans un petit siège et là je
vois le médecin et l'inter n'en fasse de
moi qui vous disent que votre mari va
partir en fumée c'est pas possible parce
que j'avais appelé une demi heure avant
pour demander si pronostic vital était
engagé au payement dit non jeudi mais
jeudi les plus engagés là maintenant on
dit il engager mais où madame oui et là
mais je l'aimé c'est pas possible de le
voir
oui oui je plains j'avoue dj de voir une
dernière fois au moins une fois en plus
il était consciente qu'elle était pas du
tout un tube et encore il avait la
grosse machine pour respirer mais
n'était pas intubé et moelleux le
médecin m'a dit si ça va pas mieux
je viens tibet votre mari mais j'aime il
ya des chances que la machine elle
marche la grosse machine que vous me
parlez il ya une chance sur huit
je ne sais pas qui c'est enfin il avait
sept chances sur 8,2 pour eux deux et
puis bajoyers dans le rose yoko active
mais vous avez des enfants bah oui 2
vous avez demandé à le voir avec vos
deux filles à la mémoire de celle déjà
gpa est interdite la johan vous pensez
vous rire sans voir vos deux petites
filles sans roues à votre femme en fait
au moment où il me dit ça
là je prends conscience que que tout est
terminé quoi et tout de suite je pense à
ma femme et mes filles et il me dit
voilà on va on va faire le maximum mais
mais voilà c'est considérer que
que certains croient ce avait passé 18
jours en réanimation est ce qu on vous
lit et me lie à ce moment là on vous dit
ça il devrait pas s'en sortir mais
c'étaient des hauts des bas des hauts
des bas tous les jours tous les jours en
fin c'était tout est dans le coma ses
hobbies jours dans le coma
un jour ça allait le lendemain ça
m'allait pu enfin m'ont dit on connaît
maintenant le coc vite c'est comme ça le
matin ça va le soir ça va mieux c'est
on va essayer de le réveiller trop super
je vais voir la grande je dis bah ils
ont réveillé papa mais le lendemain
matin
trop contente je rappelle ben non ça
s'est mal passé il était agitée on l'a
donc j'ai leur plongée dans le coma à
les mines
c'est là vous vous en servir un miracle
eut une racoleuse mans vous devenez
officiellement le patient le plus jeune
de france à sortir de réanimation et si
on vous a aujourd'hui c'est que ce que
vous avez trente six ans et qui a
beaucoup de jeunes
voilà qui lisent ça pour moi voilà c'est
pas pour moi mais ils voient que vous
vous êtes un rescapé
vous avez vu la mort de très très près
complètement vous pensiez que jamais
ressenti aux fibres faute femme c'était
fini pour vous balleux le truc c'est
qu'il faut savoir au moment où au moment
où il m'a dit ça va très très vite
et pour le coup ce qui est assez cruel
c'est que je m'endors en pleurant quoi
et les derniers mots que j'ai eu c'est
ces voix là c'est considérer que c'est
la fin alors vous sortez de la sorte et
d'hôpital je change de jeu par de réa je
repasse dans un troisième service co
vide et là j'apprends que le patient qui
est dans la chambre derrière moi a fait
quatre tests pcr négatif alors qu'il a
tous les symptômes
alors là je pose la question je me dis
mais moi j'ai fait un test
j'avais tous les symptômes pourquoi il
était négatif
et là j'apprends que si le virus est
passé dans les bronches
il est il est plus détectable c'est ça
donc
donc j'étais déjà contaminé pour le coup
et moi voilà si si vraiment j'ai accepté
de parler à la presse
si l'image a fait le tour de la france
et bien j'en suis heureux parce que à la
base c'était c'était vraiment j'ai pris
conscience qu'il fallait vraiment que je
témoigne est vraiment que je fasse en
sorte de d'inciter les gens à respecter
les gestes barrière alors il surtout sur
mon âge il ya beaucoup de gens qui vous
voit ce soir on est en direct à 21h16
sur s'est vite il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent yoann c'est un miraculé et
revient de loin mais on sent extrêmement
a qu'un psychologue gicm ans pour
pourquoi vous êtes encore dans cet état
il faut savoir que j'ai c'est bête mais
moi je suis un fidèle de l'émission
depuis le premier jour et tous les jours
le seul moment de bonheur que j'avais
c'est quand j'avais ma femme et mes
enfants téléphone et quant à prendre et
à laisser commencer parce que je savais
que j'avais passé une bonne soirée
et voilà ouais c'est vous tous vous
m'avez voilà vous vous m'avez aidé et en
écoutant tous les témoignages
j'ai pris conscience de beaucoup de
choses je sais que par là où je suis
passé j'aurais plus jamais la même vie
j'ai joué actuellement dans une bulle je
suis dans le monde des bisounours
je sais que ça peut être dangereux parce
que je sais que j'ai tendance
aujourd'hui a pu le voir le mal et voilà
je veux dire c'est la vie est trop
précieuse
donc j'ai je sais vous vivez l'enfer
financièrement parce que oui non et
c'est à wayne on s'est vraiment on va
jusqu'au bout du truc à moi je suis
entreprise est à l'arrêt depuis
maintenant je suis artisan peintre
décorateur et j'avais deux gros
chantiers sur novembre et décembre qui
sauvé mon année ce que j'ai démarré fin
2018 et et là je permets de chantier
et donc là c'est la cata donc là c'est
la cata 0 revenu 0 euros de revenus
depuis combien de temps depuis deux mois
donc j'appelle le j'appelle les impôts
je leur explique la situation
elles me disent mais monsieur vous
n'avez pas le droit à la prime dès 1500
euros la prime de base pour vraiment
garder un minimum sur sur les charges et
il m'a dit maintenant vous n'avez pas le
droit vous êtes en arrêt de travail
j'ai effectivement je suis en arrêt de
travail
mais si je suis en arrêt de travail
c'est dû à la crise sanitaire donc là je
pense que je vais me faire quand même
aidé par eux par l'état j'ai un je
reçois ce cette attestation de la
sécurité sociale elmer lach les appels
et je leur dis mais pourquoi je suis à 0
il doit y avoir une erreur
non parce que au moment où vous avez
essayé de créer votre entreprise vous
étiez au chômage
donc on prend pas on prend pas en compte
le chômage donc sur sur une année de
travail
ils en ont calculé 3 je suis en dessous
du du seuil
ce qui fait que j'ai j'ai ça aujourd'hui
on va on va essayer de vous aider vous
savez on essayait de de vous remettre
valeur de redonner un petit coup de
pouce pour que vous essayer de repartir
je voudrais vous remercier
on va s'y témoignages on va vous garder
le moral
ce que vous êtes sorti vraiment de
l'enfer et je voudrais que yoann vieille
et je voulais vraiment que vous direz
une vienne témoigner ce soir pour vous
montrer qu'il a 36 ans et qu'il est
passé à sa est la mort donc c'est
vraiment une saloperie ce virus mais à
son support à risque il faut le dire
merci et chinois wing lourdes il me dit
un truc dans l'oreillette oui et brico
dépôt
voilà nous aident puisqu'on va vous
aider avec eux et vous allez voir ce
qu'on va essayer de faire pour vous pour
que vous puissiez vous relancez merci
emilie merci yoann garder le moral -
johan et use est plus jeune vous allez
repartir et vous aller rebondir